[Musique]
j'ai vu détruire un bidonville
je suis passer ensuite devant deux
autres entièrement rasé et de là j'ai
gagné un foyer logement c'est à dire
deux grandes tours pour célibataires où
sont logés plusieurs centaines de ce qu
on a arraché aux mines en ville et
ensuite je suis allé visiter ce qu'on
appelle une cité de relogement ou alors
là c'était les familles et des familles
généralement nombreuses
si bien que je suis sorti de là avec une
nuée d'enfants à côté de moi qui étais
des enfants du bonheur alors qu'avant
ils étaient les enfants de la pouillerie
et ce qui a été très émouvant et qu'un
un tout petit bonhomme qui avait
peut-être sept huit ans un randonnée
s'est tourné vers moi et m'a dit à
monsieur est ce que tu vas en faire
d'autres plus pour ceux qui restent
les belges y en est en train on est en
train
d'ailleurs en 18 mois nous avons réduit
de 20 mille le nombre de ceux qui vivent
dans les bidonvilles
il reste actuellement entre 35000 et 40
personnes dans des bidons et l'action
s'intensifie je vais vous dire qu'on a
consacré 170 millions cette année
cette action est que les crédits de l'an
prochain ont avoisiné 200 millions il
faut qu'on comprenne qu en france on ne
peut pas laisser encore des dizaines de
milliers d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
français ou non vivre dans ces
conditions il faut que à la fin de 73
pratiquement ce soit fini à paris et en
province car nous avons en province
quelques cas difficiles et là aussi il
va falloir que les préfets les maires
s'y mettent
et puis qu'on ne raconte pas qu'on ne
peut pas faire un peu de place des
familles qui quittent des bidonvilles
il ya là une forme nouvelle de
ségrégation qui est intolérable et pour
ma part je suis parfaitement décidés à
lutter contre et a cassé de les
résidences ce que vous avez vu un auteur
vaut plus tu as parfaitement c'est une
des meilleures matinée depuis je suis
prime
[Musique]